uh kirk franklin yeah kirk talking to
his son
yeah but if someone's coming at him
crazy let me hear it by the way this is
like a family thing so i'm sure my
family's doing this
let him see it first it's hard to hear
the kids the kids yeah yeah
how's the kid
yeah he's like a full-grown man okay
hold on there's some family stuff though
that's what i'm saying it's family stuff
[Music]
that he his dad if he came in his dad
right he came at his dad
yeah he couldn't we know he came at his
death kurt franklin said he's like for
one he said he'd like to keep his
business private family businesses
of course does his son put on try to put
his dad on blast like oh you think
you're you know this guy's so perfect
and all that look at how he threatened
cheat uh treat his son
and stuff like that i'm like man this is
it's not again get your skinny
[ __ ] ass back out of the
goddamn way before i put my foot up your
ass
this son must do something i will break
your neck if you ever disrespect me
this is this between him at the white
world yeah what do we have to cancel the
dad now yeah right
that's what i'm saying it's so stupid it
like it has nothing to do with us that's
not that's not our family that's
exactly that's not that has nothing to
do with us so i don't give a [ __ ]
the funny thing about this is plies
here's applies no no i don't know what
you're saying i haven't seen anything
hello that was me he goes that was me
not my dog on that phone that was me
because if you ever hear plies on
instagram he sounds just like that
oh yeah he looks just like him yeah he
looks like him yeah
he looks just like him like this this is
a random thing that he did
a lot real real quick i had a
conversation with my home girl about
10-15 minutes ago
she want to get all the surgery done she
want to get a butt done
a chest done a stomach flat a way small
i'm not saying justin what reminds me of
justin logan
i just told her i said you did you know
what you get all the done phone you've
been attracted she said no
i said [ __ ]
[Laughter]
about all this you know who care about
looks more than anybody in the world who
a [ __ ] ugly [ __ ]
speaking facts
well that's pretty much you kind of get
the same vibe
yeah he's such you know he's he's a
motivation is so good
him singing oh it's so funny he got rid
of his grills right
yeah he got his teeth now a lot of
rappers starting to do yeah yeah they're
growing up
well these young rappers as well i think
it's i think it's just a [ __ ]
teeth are already [ __ ] high
maintenance as it is i think they
realize how ridiculous yes
i'm still going to get a grill no matter
what you're gonna get a grill but yeah
the one
i thought you're just gonna get the one
the going back
i thought you could get that one gold
what they're gonna get the one goal
oh yeah a lot and i'll tell you i lost
my [ __ ] two oh cap you're gonna get a
cake yeah i got a room
i got a root canal and uh which wasn't
bad
uh and the cap fell out or whatever so
i'm gonna get a gold cap you know what
i'm saying
that's tight yeah sick yeah don't cancel
that man no i mean that's her family
yeah that's family [ __ ] if my son came
at me crazy
has your dad ever said some wild [ __ ] to
you nah not like that
no not like that were you about to ask
me if i did
it because i was like he asked you yeah
[Applause]
hello
[ __ ] to you um no my asian parents never
really
talked they hit yeah yeah yeah chan you
just hit
yeah straight up just hit no word
straight huh
yeah they hit they don't have to say
anything you'll see the look in their
eyes and you're like
[ __ ] it's over i can see it in your eyes
how about that
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this is from a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together come on
i'm just saying dude grab that mic son